quatre nouveaux cas d'intoxication
alimentaire ont été détectés aujourd'hui
ce qui porte à 18 le nombre de personnes
hospitalisées après avoir mangé des
steaks hachés surgelés vendus chez
leclerc pratiquement tous sont des
enfants du sud ouest les premières
analyses ont permis d'isoler une
bactérie le fournisseur une usine du
maine et loire est en cause
claudine gilbert 18 personnes
hospitalisées dont 16 enfants tous
contaminés par du steak haché surgelé
la coupable est sûre les chats coli une
bactérie secal dont l'un gestion peut
provoquer une forme gravissime de gastro
entérite les malades les plus atteints
souffre de graves insuffisances rénales
l'atteinte rénale reste finalement très
dépendante de la réponse immunitaire et
de la quantité probablement de toxines
ingéré donc il y a une plus grande
vulnérabilité des jeunes enfants ce père
de famille vit dans l'angoissé depuis
trois jours les reins de sa fillette de
quatre ans ont été endommagés elle a dû
être dialysé je pensais que c'était une
gastro entérite aiguë 24 entérite au
départ et a pu après ces incidents
gastro entérite aiguë puisque
effectivement les laisse elle était très
très importante
et puis et puis voilà après le sel le
diagnostic du syndrome hémolytique et
urémique est arrivé au bout de
quatre jours plus tard l'origine de
l'intoxication a été identifiée dimanche
il s'agit de steaks hachés de la marque
chantegril produit ici dans le maine et
loire une usine du groupe soviba le
numéro trois français des viandes de
grande consommation selon la direction
la contamination pourrait avoir eu lieu
le 22 août dernier lors de l'abattage ou
du conditionnement d'un lot de 25 bête à
l'origine ça peut être un animal malade
mais ça reste quand même à démontrer ça
peut être aussi porté par différents
vecteurs personnes les autres en aucun
cas ce qu'on peut affirmer aujourd'hui
c'est que ça ça touche nos plans de
nettoyage nos plans de fabrication
trois cent mille pièces de ce steak
haché ont été distribués dans le réseau
leclerc du sud ouest la priorité
désormais récupérer toutes les boîtes
déjà vendus pour éviter de nouvelles
contaminations